les cancers pédiatriques voilà un sujet
dont on parle peu tente il est
douloureux et compliqué et ces trois
personnes le savent bien marie thibeault
fondatrice du collectif stop au cancer
de nos enfants laurence une toxicologue
et jean françois corty médecins ont
signé en janvier dernier une tribune
dans le monde pour alerter sur l'urgence
sanitaire que représentent les cancers
chez les enfants de notre point de vue
il ya des indicateurs qui aujourd'hui
nous montre que le cancer pédiatrique
relève d'une urgence sanitaire parce que
le nombre de cas augmente régulièrement
depuis plusieurs années et on a vraiment
voulu tirer la sonnette d'alarmé sur un
problème qui de notre point de vue est
occulté il y a de fait un déni des
autorités sur cette réalité sanitaire on
estime chaque année en france à 2500 le
nombre de nouveaux cas est à 500 le
nombre de décès sur l'ensemble du
territoire certaines villes semblent
bien plus concernés que d'autres c'est
le cas de sainte pazanne près de nantes
25 enfants atteints de cancer depuis
2015 16 cas entre 2011 et 2020 répartis
dans le haut jura ou encore onze cas
entre 2018 et 2020 dans leurs trois
clusters identifié par les autorités
alors qu'un quatrième pourrait toucher
saint rogatien près de la rochelle où
six malades ont été recensés entre 2018
et 2019 les habitants de ces communes
dénonce des nombreux élevé de cancers
dus aux causes environnementales
ce que réfute santé publique france les
premières conclusions confirment qu'un
nombre de leucémies pédiatrique dans
cette zone est plus important
qu'ailleurs en france mais aucune
anomalie environnementales ou
industriels n'a été détectée et nous
n'avons pas non plus trouvé de facteurs
d'exposition commun chez les enfants en
coordination avec le registre national
des cancers et le chu de rouen nous
allons continuer de suivre l'apparition
de leucémie dans le temps pour voir si
les chiffres évoluent un mois plus tard
une réponse similaire est donnée aux
habitants de l'heure mais pour sainte
pazanne en loire atlantique la situation
est bien plus alarmante ils nous l'ont
pas annoncer directement c'est par la
presse que nous avons appris que
finalement le cluster n'existait plus un
autre grande sept ans à notre grande
incompréhension parce que il ya
vingt-cinq enfants qu'on déclaré un
cancer sur un secteur sur un temps donné
très courts et l'a7 qui sont décédés ils
ont fait en sorte que finalement on
puisse dire circulez ya rien à voir
maintenant il ya à voir il ya des
enfants qui tombent malades il ya des
enfants qui meurent donc rien quand ça
finalement qu'est cluster ok pas cluster
ça devrait aller bien au delà c'est à
dire que là il ya des enfants qui
meurent il ya des enfants qui tombent
malades ça ne s'arrête pas il faut aller
chercher ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est au-delà d'un mot c'est
vraiment ça veut dire que nos
institutions nos autorités sanitaires
elles doivent créer ce qui n'existe pas
encore aujourd'hui c'est à dire de la
recherche environnementale
quand il y à des cancers pédiatriques
mais alors si ce n'est pas
environnementale d'où cela peut-il venir
le rnt est ce registre national des
tumeurs solides de l'enfant surveille
les cancers chez les moins de 18 ans en
france métropolitaine et dans les
départements d'outre-mer et plus
précisément l'incidence dans les
populations considérées à risque comme
les enfants habitant près de centrale
nucléaire de lignes à haute tension ou
de routes à grande circulation
pourtant le lien de cause à effet a du
mal à être établie on cherche des
facteurs de risque massif et c'est la
seule chose qu'on va pouvoir détecter et
ça souvent ça n'existe pas après ils
restent des facteurs environnementaux
mineurs avec des facteurs génétiques et
des expositions à tout un tas de choses
qui font qu'on ne pourra pas mettre le
doigt sur la chose arranz et
scientifique déplore également l'absence
de mesures préventives
les dépistages repéré à un stade avancé
et le peu d'essais cliniques des
problèmes liés à un manque de moyens
selon certains pourtant l'assemblée
nationale avait voté en octobre dernier
pour une rallonge de 20 millions d'euros
en faveur de la recherche contre le
cancer chez les enfants
à l'échelle mondiale la crise sanitaire
de kobe 19 n'a pas facilité les choses
selon une étude publiée le 3 mars 2021
sur le site des vingt-sept en
particulier dans 79 des pays les moins
riches ou 78 % des médecins interrogés
ont déclaré que les soins délivrés aux
jeunes patients malades avaient été
affectés par la pandémie de coronavirus
34% des praticiens ont noté une
augmentation de patients abandonnant
leur traitement et 7% de ses hôpitaux
ont totalement fermé leurs services de
cancers pédiatriques en moyenne durant
10 jours pendant la pandémie